llegó el momento de hablar de salud en
directo américa ya está conmigo en el
estudio más romeros a la mar viernes ya
para descansar de esta semana a movida a
noticiosa menta y también sobre todas
las noticias de salud ayer se conmemoró
el día contra la violencia machista en
todo el planeta hablemos ahora de la
consecuencia que tiene esta problemática
en la salud de las mujeres pues de raúl
las consecuencias son muchas ayer
avanzábamos algunas de ellas y es que
hay más de 730 millones de mujeres que
en algún momento de su vida han sufrido
violencia física o sexual a lo largo de
su vida eso pues es definitivamente un
problema de salud pública repasemos las
cifras de la organización mundial de la
salud sobre en los impactos que tiene la
violencia machista en la salud de las
mujeres supervivientes no el 42 por
ciento de las mujeres que han sufrido
algún tipo de agresión física o sexual
termina con lesiones además también las
que han sufrido violencia sexual tienen
1,5 veces más probabilidades de sufrir
algún tipo de enfermedad de transmisión
sexual y por supuesto también hablemos
de la salud mental la organización
mundial de la salud asegura que las
supervivientes física o sexual tienen el
doble de probabilidades de sufrir
depresión a lo largo de su vida esto por
supuesto sin hablar de las que no
sobrevivieron también no son 800 87 87
mil mujeres las que murieron en 2020 por
roa de feminicidios no es una cifra muy
alejada por ejemplo de las que murieron
por vih también que son un millón
aproximadamente y entre ellas también
siempre muy importante mencionar las
mujeres trans que en américa latina
tienen una esperanza de vida de 35 años
hablemos de la otra cara de la moneda
como los sesgos de género pueden afectar
la salud de las mujeres desde la ciencia
además a propósito también este fue
nuestro tema del día ayer y también
afecta a la economía es que es un
problema grande por supuesto es un
problema estructural el machismo el
patriarcado afecta a todas las partes
del mundo y la ciencia pues no está
exenta tampoco la salud no uno de los
principales riesgos que existen por
ejemplo nos lo explicaba patricia canut
de la asociación las dos cifras las que
hace divulgación científica feminista y
con perspectiva social escuchemos lo que
nos contaba
al sujeto que se investiga es al hombre
para demás es quien está investigando
no vemos que en todas las
investigaciones científicas y sobre todo
en el ámbito de salud en la medicina las
personas que han hecho las
investigaciones han sido hombres por lo
tanto ha sido aún más fácil que se
perpetuará el sistema de auto
investigarse no mar y continuamos
conversando sobre este tema qué
consecuencias tiene esta falta de
estudios pues esta falta también como de
perspectiva feminista de género en los
estudios afecta muchísimas enfermedades
no desde que algunas dolencias se
invisibilizan hasta que hay otras que
por ejemplo se sobre médica no hay un
ejemplo muy concreto que son las
enfermedades cardiovasculares y por eso
también patricia nos la comentaba
escuchemos cuando una mujer tiene
síntomas de
una enfermedad cardiovascular estos
síntomas no son iguales que los síntomas
que tienen los hombres entonces que ha
pasado que muchas veces muchas mujeres
que han podido tener estos síntomas han
ido
bueno han acudido a centros de salud y
seguramente no se les había
diagnosticado esto que ha acabado
pasando que muchas veces ha acabado en
enfermedades graves o incluso en la
muerte
la al final las enfermedades
cardiovasculares son la principal causa
de muerte en las mujeres en todo el
mundo no y la ciencia ha tardado mucho
en darse cuenta de que los síntomas que
se presentan por ejemplo en los ataques
de corazón son distintos entre los
hombres y las mujeres de ese
conocimiento tampoco además no ha
llegado siempre a la población general
entonces repasemos los momentos si te
parece los síntomas más conocidos de un
ataque al corazón son el dolor de pecho
en el brazo izquierdo pero eso afecta
sobre todo más a los hombres en las
mujeres también se puede detectar un
ataque al corazón por ejemplo con
síntomas como una fatiga inusual de
náuseas mareos dolores en otras zonas
del torso como la espalda por ejemplo o
el cuello no y pues al final no saber
que esto es unos síntomas de ataque al
corazón le ha costado la vida a muchas
mujeres y precisamente pues por esa
falta de investigación y por esa falta
de conocimiento y ante cualquier cosa es
ahora nuestro cuerpo más mejor ir de
inmediato al médico para evitar
cualquier tipo de aplicación le pregunto
entonces que otras enfermedades que
afecte a que las mujeres se
invisibilizan pues a mí me gustaría
hablar de otro gran ejemplo de este tipo
de problemas que afectan a las mujeres
en la salud que es la endometriosis es
una enfermedad donde básicamente el
tejido que recubre el útero por dentro
empieza a crecer también por fuera eso
puede ser muy doloroso y ha tardado
muchísimo en saberse información sobre
esta enfermedad repasemos los datos
también afecta a 190 millones de mujeres
en todo el mundo y personas con útero
aproximadamente una de cada 10 en todo
el mundo un tercio de estas mujeres
tener esta enfermedad les ha provocado
infertilidad y a pesar de estas grandes
magnitudes de las que estamos hablando
la media de tiempo de diagnóstico es de
7 años es decir tarda mucho en
diagnosticar y eso por qué pues porque
eso se asociaba a un problema de ciclo
menstrual también se sabe que se supone
además no con los ciclos menstruales
tienen que doler nos eso no es así y por
eso también pues se tardaba tanto en
saber que está una enfermedad que
afectaba las mujeres se receptará se
recetaban además anticonceptivos cuando
eso no tienen por qué ayudar para
regular este ciclo menstrual y es un
gran ejemplo de esta sobre medicación
también de los cuerpos de las mujeres
que al final pues esto se tiene que
solucionar con más mujeres más
identidades diversas en el mundo de la
ciencia para para acumular un
conocimiento que no sea unidireccional
al final marc gracias por toda la
información nos vemos el lunes con más
salud aquí en directo américa ya
descansé bien merecido fin de semana
nosotros vamos con nuestro segundo
invitado